How's it going everyone and welcome to
the final video in my weekly profile
series and that will be on TGIF. So what
is TGIF? TGIF is going to revolve around
a classic expansion weekly profile. So
if you haven't already seen that video,
it is crucial to understand that. So go
ahead and go back into this playlist and
that will be the first video in the
playlist. Check that out before watching
more of this video. But when we have a
classic expansion week, we have
expansion through Thursday. What is
TGIF? Well, TGIF is going to be looking
to trade that wick low to the close of
the weekly candle or the wick high to
the close of the weekly candle in a
bullish scenario. Now, how do we do
that? Well, we're going to be focused on
Friday alone. So, what are the steps to
look for a valid TGIF setup? We need to
have the low in a bullish scenario
formed on Monday or Tuesday, right? This
will be the same as a classic expansion
week. From here, we want to see
expansion through Thursday. So
generally, it's best if it's 3 days of
expansion, but Tuesday, Wednesday, and
Thursday and we needed to hit a key
level or the drawn liquidity. If our key
level has not been hit, it doesn't make
sense to look back into the range,
right? We would be wanting to see a
continuation into that key level. So
once both of those things have been met,
we can then look for Friday to return
back into the range which forms the
what? The wick of the weekly candle. And
with a bearish scenario, it looks the
same, but it is just reversed. Now, what
do we actually want to look to target on
this profile? Well, with a classic
expansion week, we want to see price
close near the lows. Now, with that,
we'd want to look for 20 to 30% of the
weekly range. So going from the high of
the week to the low of the week, 20 to
30% here or 0.2 or 0.3 on a fib. That's
the area we want to see price go back up
to on Friday, or go back down to on
Friday here. Let's get into TradingView
and go over a few examples. So, here we
are in our first example, and you can
see that price is trending up. What do
we have here? We have price taking out
these equal lows, as well as reaching
into this fair value gap here, which we
can mark out. Now, with this, we have a
nice V-shape reversal, and you can see
that by a fair value gap here and a fair
value gap here.
And that forms a change in the state of
delivery. So, with this change in the
state of delivery, we could anticipate
price to continue higher. We have
expansion. This is looking like a
retracement. So, we could look for the
retracement to end, a new protected
swing to form, and to trade higher.
Let's see what happens. But, here we do
get a move lower on Monday. Tuesday,
what do we do? We have a candle to
closure, which is ideal, because it is
forming a protected swing. And so, then
now we could be looking for a
continuation on Wednesday and Thursday,
but this video is about TGIF. Now, here
what do we see? We have expansion
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday. So, a
classic expansion week. Now, do we hit
an objective? We do. We take out this
high here on the left. So, all the
requirements have been met for a valid
TGIF. We have a low on Tuesday,
expansion through Thursday, and we hit a
higher time frame key level. So, this is
where we could be looking for price to
trade lower. Now, generally speaking, if
Thursday forms a reversal, we can look
for Friday to continue off of that. If
Thursday doesn't form a reversal, then
we are looking for Friday to form that
reversal. So, let's go down to the
hourly time frame. Now, down here on the
hourly time frame, has Thursday formed a
reversal? No. So, we're going to be
looking for Friday to form that
reversal.
So, let's see what happens. Do we go and
take out this previous high? Here, we
take out the previous high. We want to
look for either confirmation via
candlesticks, or a change in the state
of delivery. I prefer a change in the
state of delivery earlier into the day
as the volatility is lower, but if we
get into New York, we can use just the
candles closures.
So, right here, we make a new high. We
could be waiting for a new change in the
state of delivery here. And now it's a
bit further away. You can see we don't
form a change in the state of delivery
here. And here now you can see
we have a new move up sweeping out a
high. So, I could either use this candle
closure, candle two closure as we're
into New York now, or wait for a close
through this up close candle here.
Now, this is where I could be looking
for price to trade lower. Now, with a
candle two closure, what are we going to
mark out here because it has a larger
wick? We'll mark out 0.5 of the wick.
And that's what we'd want to see. Price
reach up, form an intra candle change in
the state of delivery, and then trade
lower. What is lower? This low here, or
what can we mark out? The whole weekly
candle range
from low to high.
Mark out our 0.2 to 0.3. And that gives
us an area that we can look to trade
back into, which also lines up with the
PD arrays around that, which is just
this low here.
So, that is what we could be looking for
on this move here.
And we do go ahead and get that.
So, just to review, a TGIF is a
retracement or a reversal on Friday that
forms the wick of the weekly candle. You
can see early in the week here we form
the lower wick. So, we open, we form the
low, then we trend through Thursday,
hitting a higher time frame key level,
and then Friday's move is actually
forming the wick of this weekly candle.
So, let's get into another example. So,
here we are in our next example, and
what do we notice here? We have some
previous lows,
equal lows as well down here.
And so, we can go ahead and mark those
out. Now, what do we notice? We have
Tuesday forming a high here. Do we get
expansion on Wednesday? We do. Do we get
expansion on Thursday? Yes, we do. Now,
why would I not be looking for Friday to
come back into the range here? Well, we
have never hit any relevant level. So,
this is not where I'd be looking for
Friday to continue back into the range
to form the weekly wick, but we're going
to see a continuation to reach for this
target.
So, here you can see, we reach lower.
Now, on the new week, what do we do? We
open up. We reach into this gap. So, are
we going to form a high Monday or
Tuesday?
Here we get a Tuesday with a candle two
closure. Now, do we expand Wednesday and
Thursday? We do.
Now, once again, what are we doing? We
are just shy of this relevant level. So,
I would not want to be looking for
Friday to come back into the range yet
because I'd want to see it trade into
the low first. So, these are examples of
where you're not going to be looking for
TGIF, even though there's a high on
Monday or Tuesday and we have expanded
off of it because we haven't hit those
relevant levels. And that's why it's
important to actually look at the daily
chart. Do we have relevant levels and
not just go off of what the candles are
doing. So, here you can see, we do get a
little retracement to form that weekly
wick, but we get a continuation on
Friday because we have yet to hit that
relevant level on Thursday. So, these
are just examples of where TGIF does not
apply. So, here we are in our next
example and what do we have? We have
Monday making move higher. Tuesday has a
candle two closure. What do we get on
Wednesday?
Wednesday, we get a continuation lower.
We also get a continuation lower on
Thursday. You can see, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday have expanded. Now,
have we hit a relevant level? Well, we
have a fair value gap up here and right
here, but we have traded through both of
those. So, I wouldn't consider them
relevant anymore. We have a fair value
gap here and a candle with no wick. So,
this is an example of where if we are
looking for Friday to form the wick,
we'd first want to see it hit its
relevant level. We could be looking for
a continuation lower. And if we get a
reaction down here, then we can look for
it to come back into the range. Let's go
to the hourly time frame here. Now, what
do we do if we actually want to trade
this? So, we want to first wait for that
relevant level to be hit.
So, here we do, open below. And we reach
into that relevant level. Now, here is
where we need to wait for this wick of
the daily candle to form. If we're
trying to trade this move counter trend,
we want to have some sort of
confirmation that the daily low has
formed that we can trade away from. We
can either do that by waiting for an
hourly change in the state of delivery,
or if we get into New York, a lower time
frame change in the state of delivery,
or we can use candle closures.
So, let's say for instance, we go to the
4-hour time frame. We could wait for a
4-hour candle closure that is bullish.
And here we do get that 4-hour candle
closure that is bullish. So, I zoom out,
go ahead and put on my indicator that
will show my 4-hour and 15-minute model.
Let's see what happens.
Here you can see, we have what? A
reversal with a change in the state of
delivery, and then we have continuations
forming. We have a continuation there,
as well as what? A new continuation
forming when we close over this level.
This means I could take an entry on the
open, put my stop on the low. Now, why
am I choosing this low? Because it's
below the EQ of this previous candle.
And I could be looking for 2R. Let's see
what happens.
And there we get our 2R.
So, just to review, why could this trade
work out? Well, because we have a TGIF
setup. We have Tuesday or Monday forming
the high of the week, expansion through
Thursday. We hit a relevant level. Now,
on this particular example, we hit the
relevant level on Friday, but once we
hit that relevant level, we can look to
trade it back into the range to form the
wick of the weekly candle.
So, here we are in this next example,
and let's just take a look at this in
hindsight. So, what do we have? We have
a expansion, consolidation, and then we
expand again. So, what do we notice? We
have Tuesday forming a low, Wednesday
expanding, Thursday expanding. Now, why
wouldn't we be looking for a TGIF here?
Well, because we have the previous highs
over here.
Now, you may be saying, "Well, aren't
these considered a relevant level as
well?" And yes, you consider those a
relevant level, but we want to take a
look at the phases of price around those
levels. Right? We want to see do we
actually reverse off of that level, or
do we retrace or consolidate for a
continuation? And you can see as we
expand into this level here,
right? We take it out. Do we get a
reversal? No. A reversal would have
looked like this, where we take out this
high, we have a nice V-shape reversal
there. But, what do we get? We take out
the high, we get a small retracement,
and then a continuation.
Which tells us that we're not looking
for a TGIF, and it's okay to trade this
towards this higher time frame
objective, because we are not reversing
off of this high. So, we can get a
continuation. Now, if you ever want to
learn concepts, the best way to do it is
just in hindsight. Go find examples in
the chart. Quit trying to test yourself
on knowledge that you haven't learned.
Go learn it first, then test yourself.
So, that's why I'm showing an example
like this. It already has formed. I
already know what is happening. That's
how I learn. So, let's get into one more
example. So, here we are in our last
example, and you'll notice not everyone
is picture-perfect, right? But, let's
take a look at this. Monday we have the
consolidation, Tuesday we sweep out
Monday and Friday to form a new swing
candle two closure. Wednesday we expand
into an objective, right? On Thursday we
hit that objective and form a reversal
candle. So, this can also be a TGIF, but
this is where Thursday forms the
reversal, and this is where Friday is a
continuation day. So, if we go down to
the hourly time frame, what are we
looking for if we want to trade a a
in Friday? Well, we want to see an
hourly change in the state of delivery
and then we can be looking for this to
trade back lower. So, if we remove the
drawings, we have hit our higher time
frame objective, we've expanded from
Tuesday, Wednesday into Thursday, but
Thursday forms a reversal, so we can
look for Friday to get a small
continuation lower or reach back into
the weekly range. And here you can see
it's a bit choppy, but we do get that
continuation or that move back into the
range on Friday.
Now, I hope you found this weekly
profile series helpful. If you did,
please consider liking and subscribing.
And if you want a new series, please let
me know in the comment section below
what you would like to see. So, with
that said, thanks for watching and I'll
see you guys next week. Have a good one.